il y a quelques pays -- la Côte d'Ivoire, le Kenya, l'Éthiopie,
la Tanzanie et le Sénégal se portent plutôt bien en ce moment.
Mais qu'avons-nous mal fait ?
Je vais soulever huit points.
Il en faut plus que les points positifs.
(Rires)
Nous avons mal fait huit choses.
Numéro 1 : alors même que nous croissions,
nous n'avons pas créé assez d'emplois.
Nous n'avons pas créé d'emplois pour nos jeunes.
Le chômage des jeunes sur le continent est d'environ 15%,
et le sous-emploi est un véritable problème.
La deuxième chose, c'est que la qualité de la croissance n'était pas suffisante.
Même les emplois créés étaient à faible rendement,
donc nous avons déplacé les gens de l'agriculture à faible rendement
au commerce à faible rendement et au travail dans des secteurs informels
dans les zones urbaines.
La troisième chose, c'est que l'inégalité a augmenté.
Nous avons créé plus de milliardaires.
50 milliardaires qui valent 96 milliards de dollars
possèdent plus que les 75 millions de gens les plus pauvres du continent.
La pauvreté,
la proportion de gens dans la pauvreté --
c'est la 4e chose -- a bien diminué,
mais les chiffres absolus n'ont pas bougé à cause de la croissance démographique.
La croissance démographique est un sujet
dont nous ne parlons pas assez sur le continent.
Je pense que nous devons mieux la gérer,
surtout dans notre façon d'éduquer nos filles.
C'est ça la meilleure voie pour ce type de problématique.
La 5ème chose, c'est que nous n'avons pas assez investi dans l'infrastructure.
Nous avons eu des investissements de Chine.
Ça a aidé quelques pays, mais ce n'est pas assez.
La consommation d'électricité sur le continent africain,
dans l'Afrique sub-saharienne est équivalente à celle de l'Espagne.
La consommation totale est équivalente à celle de l'Espagne.
Beaucoup de personnes vivent dans le noir,
et comme l'a dit le président
de la Banque Africaine de Développement,
l'Afrique ne peut pas se développer dans le noir.
L'autre chose que nous n'avons pas faite,
c'est que nos économies ont toujours la même structure
depuis des décennies.
Même si nous sommes en croissance,
la structure de nos économies n'a pas beaucoup changé.
Nous exportons toujours des commodités,
et l'export des commodités, c'est quoi ? C'est exporter l'emploi.
Notre valeur ajoutée manufacturière est de 11% uniquement.
Nous ne créons pas assez d'emplois décents pour nos jeunes,
et le commerce interne est trop bas.
Seulement 12% du commerce se fait entre nous.
Donc c'est un autre problème sérieux.
Puis vient la gouvernance.
La gouvernance est un gros problème.
Nos institutions sont faibles,
et parfois inexistantes, et ça laisse de la place à la corruption.
La corruption est un problème que nous contrôlons à peine,
et nous devons nous battre bec et ongles
pour une meilleure transparence dans la gestion de nos économies
et la gestion de nos finances.
Nous devons aussi faire attention aux nouveaux conflits,
aux nouveaux types de conflits,
comme celui avec Boko Haram, dans mon pays, le Nigeria,
et avec Al-Shabaab, au Kenya.
Nous devons nous allier aux partenaires internationaux,
aux pays industrialisés, pour combattre cela ensemble.
Sinon nous créons une nouvelle réalité
qui n'est pas celle que nous voulons pour une Afrique en croissance.
Et finalement, le problème de l'éducation.
Nos systèmes éducatifs dans de nombreux pays ne fonctionnent pas.
Nous n'enseignons pas les compétences nécessaires pour demain.
Nous devons trouver un meilleur moyen d'éduquer.
Ce sont les choses que nous faisons mal.
Bon, que pouvons-nous faire maintenant ?
Je crois que la meilleure chose à faire est d'apprendre à gérer le succès.
Très souvent, quand les gens, ou les pays, réussissent,
ils oublient ce qui a fait leur succès.
Savoir ce dans quoi vous excellez,
y exceller et ne pas s'arrêter est important pour nous.
Toutes ces choses que nous avons bien faites,
nous devons apprendre à les reproduire, et à bien les reproduire.
Gérer l'économie tout en créant la stabilité est vital,
redresser les prix, et avoir une cohérence politique.
Très souvent, nous ne sommes pas cohérents.
Un régime s'en va, un autre arrive
et il jette même les politiques qui fonctionnaient.
Quel en est le résultat ?
Ça crée de l'incertitude pour les gens, pour les ménages,
pour les entreprises.
Ils ne savent pas comment ni s'il faut investir.
Nous devons garder ce qui marche pour réduire notre dette,
mais maintenant les pays recommencent à emprunter,
et nous voyons notre ratio dette-PIB recommencer à grimper,
et dans certains pays,
la dette devient un problème, ce qu'il faut éviter.
Donc bien gérer le succès.
Autre chose, c'est de se concentrer
sur ce que nous avons mal fait.
En tout premier lieu : l'infrastructure.
Oui, la plupart des pays reconnaissent qu'il faut investir dedans,
et ils essaient du mieux qu'ils peuvent.
C'est un devoir.
La production énergétique est la clef du développement,
qui ne peut avoir lieu dans le noir.
Puis la gouvernance et la corruption :
nous devons nous battre.
Nous devons rendre nos pays transparents.
Et surtout, nous devons impliquer nos jeunes.
Nos jeunes ont du génie.
Je le vois tous les jours.
C'est ce qui me pousse à me lever tous les matins.
Nous devons débrider le génie de nos jeunes,
les laisser faire, les aider à créer et à innover,
à montrer la voie.
Je sais qu'ils nous mèneront dans la bonne direction.
Et nos femmes et nos filles :
nous devons reconnaître que les femmes et les filles sont une bénédiction.
Elles ont la force,
et nous devons libérer cette force
pour qu'elles puissent contribuer au continent.
Je crois fermement que lorsque nous ferons tout cela,
nous verrons que le récit d'une Afrique en croissance
n'est pas bidon.
C'est une tendance.
C'est une tendance, et si nous continuons, si nous libérons notre jeunesse,
si nous libérons nos femmes,
même si parfois nous faisons des pas en arrière,
ou des pas sur le côté,
mais la tendance est claire.
L'Afrique continuera à croître.
Je m'adresse aux entrepreneurs dans la salle,
investir dans l'Afrique n'est pas pour aujourd'hui, ou pour demain,
c'est n'est pas à court terme, mais à long terme.
Mais si vous n'investissez pas en Afrique,
alors vous louperez le coche
d'une des meilleures opportunités de croissance au monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Kelly Stoetzel : Vous avez parlé de corruption,
et vous êtes très connue pour militer contre la corruption.
Mais cela a eu des conséquences.
Certains ont contre-attaqué, et votre mère a été kidnappée.
Comment gérez-vous tout cela ?
Ngozi Okonjo-Iweala : Ça a été très difficile.
Merci d'aborder le sujet du kidnapping de ma mère.
C'est un sujet très difficile.
Mais ce que cela veut dire, c'est que quand vous combattez la corruption,
quand vous touchez aux poches de ceux qui volent de l'argent,
ils ne vous laissent pas en reste.
Ils ripostent, et ça devient un problème quand ils essaient de vous intimider,
est-ce que vous abandonnez, ou vous continuez ?
Est-ce que vous trouvez un moyen de résister et de riposter ?
La réponse des équipes avec lesquelles je travaille
est que nous devons continuer le combat.
Nous devons créer ces institutions.
Nous devons trouver des façons d'arrêter ces gens
de voler notre héritage pour le futur.
Donc c'est ce que nous avons fait.
Même si nous ne sommes plus au gouvernement, nous continuons la lutte.
Dans nos pays, personne, personne ne va combattre la corruption
pour nous, sinon nous.
Et donc, cela a des conséquences,
nous devons faire tout notre possible.
Mais je vous remercie, et remercie TED de nous donner la parole
pour qu'on leur dise qu'ils ne gagneront pas,
que nous ne serons pas intimidés.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
KS : Merci pour votre présentation et votre important travail.